we're here at CES 2012 at the GoPro
booth you're probably familiar with this
is camera it's an amazing camera but now
they have something special called the
GoPro Wi-Fi BacPac so what you do is you
add this attachment to your GoPro camera
and then with this remote you can turn
it on and off to say you're surfing you
see a wave coming you want to catch the
wave you turn record on and then you
just go for it somebody on shore can
actually watch what you're doing
remotely which is really amazing now the
other thing about this is it connects to
up to 50 cameras together okay so say
you're watching a surfing contest you
know waves come and Kelly Slater he
presses the button along with a bunch of
other guys and you can have 20 say 20
different cameras that you can cut
together I love this application I think
it's really cool so the wireless uses
802 dot 11n and the output is 1080p
you've got an SD card right here that
you can record everything to as well as
whoever is picking it up wirelessly this
is going to come out in March and it's
going to cost the camera cost 299 but
the wireless cost 99 bucks so I think is
a really great deal i can't wait to get
my hands on this and i see how it works